what some people are concerned is that
this Leninist organization which is
looking at what's happened successfully
in Salvador and Nicaragua and Venezuela
where these revolutionary governments
took power that they want to replicate
that in Colombia the guerrillas
negotiated such a generous package of
economic assistance social support for
these areas of past conflict where the
guerrillas are and actually be
resettling it's such a generous package
as a matter of fact that the Colombian
state doesn't have the means to comply
if the state doesn't comply with its
commitments it's going to be subject to
criticism so almost immediately the FARC
will attack the fact that the government
is not complying with with its
commitments under the peace agreement
the guerrillas could use that criticism
and that's the concern using the
Democratic means abusing representative
democracy and then eventually taking
power and dissolving the institutions so
that they can hold power in perpetuity
what do you think's in store for
Colombia let us know in the comments
section and let us know what other
topics you want a EEI scholars to cover
in 60 seconds